[Music]
everyone knows there's nothing quite
like a good tearjerker ending but did
you know twin peaks had not one but two
this list includes a few you might not
expect be warned though here there be
spoilers
the second and final season of fleabag
proudly announces in its first episode
that it's going to be a love story by
the end of the season though you realize
that it's not necessarily a love story
with a happy ending
the season's thrust involves the titular
character falling for a priest who
ultimately decides to remain devoted to
god in the final scene he visits her at
a bus stop and she tells him that she
loves him his reply is devastating
it'll pass
so in the end fleabag doesn't get to be
with him even though he admits he loves
her as well
it's a terribly sad ending even when you
realize by the end that fleabag will
probably be okay in a gesture that
suggests the finality of the ending she
walks away from the camera that's been
following her this entire time she no
longer needs to share her life with the
audience and the audience too needs to
be okay with it
the final moments of six feet under were
almost certainly designed in a lab to
completely devastate everyone who loves
the show as claire the baby of the
fisher family drives away from the life
she's known the show transitions to a
montage in which every single one of the
show's recurring characters meet their
maker it's a perfect summation of
death's beauty and inevitability the
show suggests that each of its main
characters go on to lead meaningful
lives and then at some point pass away
as all people must
it doesn't treat death as a cudgel or as
something that only exists to get an
emotional reaction out of viewers
instead six feet under shows death is
what it is a natural part of being alive
everything is temporary and in the final
moments of the series the show provides
a gut-wrenching reminder to hold on to
what you've got
although it's only five episodes long
chernobyl nevertheless leaves a huge
impact on its audience the series tells
the story of the chernobyl disaster with
particular focus on the bureaucracy that
proved so ineffectual in dealing with
the crisis in its final episode the show
depicts the ussr's half-hearted effort
to hold people accountable for this
ultimately a few low-level men inside
the facility are held responsible while
the entire system that they existed
within is ignored the lies that were
told about the chernobyl facility and
the conditions that led the facility to
be unsafe are not reckoned with at all
in the end valerie lagassoff the
crusader who wanted to change how the
ussr handles its nuclear facilities is
revealed to have taken his own life he
knows that the change he longs for will
not come that people are much happier
with living the life and that is a truth
he cannot live with
although each series of black adder is
set in a different era in history the
show's overall tone always remains
relatively constant the show's final
season blackadder goes forth places the
show's anti-hero and his supporting cast
in the trenches of world war one because
it's a comedy you might be tempted to
assume that blackadder is going to
trivialize the grim nature of the war
it's depicting but the show takes the
opposite approach in its final episode
blackadder and the rest of the show's
characters realize that they are about
to be sent on a suicide mission they
spend much of the episode attempting to
escape from their fate but to no avail
good luck everyone
in the show's final moments they charge
out of their trench and are presumably
mowed down in a hail of gunfire few
shows are bold enough to kill off their
entire main cast in their finale but
that's precisely what blackadder does
the finale was widely acclaimed after it
aired not just for its bravery but also
for the ruthlessness with which it is
able to depict the horrors of war
during world war 1 countless soldiers
were sent to die totally meaningless
deaths
and blackadder is one of the few shows
willing to depict that reality in full
the final moments of twin peaks are
anything but uplifting disregarding the
return which functions more as a sequel
than as a continuation of the original
series twin peaks season 2 finale leaves
things in a pretty dire state for its
heroes initially you're led to believe
that dale cooper has managed to enter
the black lodge rescue annie blackburn
and return to the town of twin peaks
unharmed in the show's final moments
however it becomes clear that dale
cooper is no longer the stand-up fbi
agent he was at the beginning of the
series
instead he's been corrupted by bob the
evil presence at the heart of the town
who was responsible for the death of
laura palmer in the final moments of its
original run twin peaks pulls the rug
out from under its audience revealing
that the show's stalwart hero is gone
having been replaced by a vision of pure
unbridled evil and although coop
certainly wouldn't be gone forever it's
not like the return gave him much of a
happy ending either
veep's ending isn't sad in the sense
that it might make you cry rather the
show devotes its final episode to the
emptiness of politics as selena attempts
to win her party's nomination for
president she reveals that she's willing
to sacrifice everyone and everything
she's supposed to care about in order to
get it she trades away her principles to
earn support from other wings of her
party and blames gary the person who has
been at her side throughout the entirety
of the show for an fbi investigation
into her charity fund selena betrays
everyone and as a result she gets
exactly what she wants ultimately though
viewers know that her victory is a
hollow one because it comes at the cost
of every character they've grown to love
from its first episode veep presents a
world in which what you achieve as an
influential politician matters far less
than how much power you accumulate in
its finale veep doubles down on that
brutal theme and digs into the dark
heart of what makes the american
political system so absurd
the ending of parenthood is dark in a
uniquely simple way it focuses on the
death of the braverman family's
patriarch zeke
the show's final moments take place
after zeke's death as we see the rest of
the braverman's assemble to play
baseball in his honor it's a beautiful
moving tribute that acts as a reminder
of the legacy that zeke has left behind
he created the family at the center of
the series and in its final moments the
show chooses to spotlight that
zeke's death is a sad event but
parenthood reminds its audience that
feeling sad is just one part of the
human experience
losing zeke feels like losing a member
of your family should it breaks your
heart but it also gives you a chance to
remember all the great things the person
did while they were alive it's
bittersweet contemplative and totally
honest
how do you end the show when your
principal characters have been dead the
whole time as it turns out the answer is
to kill them again in the final episode
of the good place all four core members
of the show's human cast have all
finally arrived in the good place
once there they're able to fulfill every
desire they've ever had eventually
though they realize that they're ready
to move on and essentially phase out of
existence itself it's a concept that's
almost too heady for tv but chidi ever
the professor explains it well life in
the good place is like a wave once you
crash on the shore you disappear but the
water you leave behind is still very
much there the wave was just a
different way for the water to be
for a little while
the good places finale is about learning
to accept the end of your own existence
specifically it's about willingly
relinquishing your identity and becoming
a positive force in the universe
death isn't the end for the show's main
characters but in the final episode they
all blink out of existence for good in a
way that goes far beyond the mere
stopping point that is physical death
the show makes clear that they've all
accepted this choice of course but that
doesn't mean it's not utterly
heartbreaking
after 11 seasons on the air no one
expected mash to do anything all that
daring in its final episode the series
finale chronicles the end of the korean
war and the party that the members of
the camp throw before they say their
tear-filled goodbyes to one another
before those farewells happen though the
show offers up a meaty plot about the
weight of the conflict and what it's
done to hawkeye pierce the show's main
character
in this episode hawkeye revisits a
traumatic incident that occurred as his
unit was returning from a beach outing
their bus eventually picked up a number
of refugees but was forced to pull off
the road in order to avoid being spotted
hawkeye specifically recalls telling a
woman to quiet her chicken and the woman
killing the chicken to keep it from
making noise everybody's life was in
danger because of that damn chicken
later on in the episode it's revealed
that hawkeye has repressed the real
memory it wasn't a chicken she was
trying to keep silent but her own baby
the woman smothered her child in order
to survive
and hawkeye can't cope with the reality
of that memory it's a dark dark turn for
the final episode of the show but one
that feels necessary even though mash is
ostensibly a comedy it never shies away
from depicting the brutal realities of
war
the series finale of merlin plays out
like a brutal tragedy from the very
beginning the show is centered around
the friendship between arthur and merlin
as arthur ascends the throne and heads
off to adventure with the rest of the
knights of the round table the show's
primary interest doesn't change in the
final episode though arthur is struck
down and merlin is unable to revive him
he's told that arthur will rise again
but neither merlin nor the audience gets
to see that happen
instead the episode follows merlin as he
spends millennia waiting for his friend
to come again he's an ageless eternal
being doomed to be traumatized by a past
that he has no power to change
while the rest of the characters in
merlin get to live complete arcs the
show's central figure must remain in
stasis the life he leads now is one a
life of waiting he's lost his best
friend and now all he can do is pray
that he'll get to see him again
someday
the ending of how i met your mother was
hugely anticipated by the show's fans
that excitement stemmed in part from the
show's premise which suggests that
eventually ted will get to the part of
the story that involves his wife the
finale does indeed reveal their first
meeting before offering an abbreviated
look at what is life with his kid's
mother played by kristin miliotti went
on to be like it's just as sweet and
romantic as fans hoped for the episode
ultimately reveals however that the
mother died in 2024
she and ted built a life together but it
wasn't one meant to last forever
although milioti only plays a prominent
role in the final arc of the show's run
she made such an enormous impression on
audiences that her death proved to be a
deeply sad and divisive event the entire
show builds up to the mother's arrival
and when audiences finally meet her she
doesn't disappoint but the show's
decisions might how i met your mother's
final episode became further
controversial for suggesting that after
the mother's death ted ultimately falls
back in love with robin to many this
choice rings hollow in part because of
all the hype that have been built around
the mother
if you present a simple and factual
account of what happens at the end of
the americans it might not seem all that
devastating philip and elizabeth the
russian spies at the center of the show
managed to safely return to the ussr
after spending years living as americans
in order to make their escape though
they have to give up the entire life
they've built in the u.s
their daughter who was supposed to join
them on their journey to the ussr
decides to stay behind and it's unclear
whether they'll ever see her again when
you dig into the human emotion at the
core of this finale it's true tragedy is
revealed philip has to tell his best
friend that he's been lying to him for
years and entrust him with looking after
the sun they're leaving behind
once more the society they're returning
to is on the brink of collapse
all of the crimes and the lies that the
two of them have been caught up in all
for the sake of their homeland will have
been for nothing they built their lives
in the u.s and were forced to abandon
those lives for a country they haven't
lived in for years and then at the end
of it all that failing country makes it
perfectly clear that it doesn't actually
care about them it's a crushing final
blow for the show's protagonists
the final episode of the leftovers has a
happy ending but it's one that comes
after an enormous amount of trauma the
finale is set more than a decade in the
future as nora lives a quiet remote life
in australia that life faces a huge
disruption when kevin her former
boyfriend and the love of her life shows
up out of the blue the entire episode is
built on the weight of the history
between these two characters
and that history is more than a little
grueling when they finally reconcile
it's a moment of enormous relief and a
reminder of how far they've both come
the leftovers is set in a world in which
two percent of the world's population
has inexplicably vanished and the show's
finale chooses not to provide any firm
answers about this instead it suggests
that what matters is how its characters
feel and whether or not they've been
able to overcome their struggles
indeed kevin and nora have certainly
struggled before but the finale suggests
that maybe just maybe there might be
cause for hope it's an optimistic ending
but one that serves to highlight the
deep sadness that the two of them have
shared throughout the series
bojack horseman's final episode opens
with the titular character being rescued
from the pool at his former house he
winds up in prison for trespassing and
finds that the routine his life takes on
in jail helps him in his battle with
addiction the finale then leaps forward
one year bojack is released for princess
caroline's wedding where he sees all of
his old friends again but it becomes
increasingly clear that these
friendships which have been the core of
the series may not last forever bojack
is a better person than he was when the
show started but he's done irreparable
harm to the people he's supposed to care
about most they still love bojack but
they know that if they're looking to
build healthy lives for themselves they
might have to leave them behind as diane
bojack's closest confidant tells him
i think there are people that help you
become the person that you end up being
and you can be grateful for them even if
they were never meant to be in your life
forever
the finale of bojack horseman is about
knowing when relationships have run
their course and allowing people to
leave your life even if it hurts in the
moment
when they see us has an ending that
could actually be described as happy
the central park five who have spent
years in prison are eventually
exonerated for the crime of sexually
assaulting a woman and the real criminal
is brought to justice in the end their
story is one of triumph but that triumph
comes at an enormous cost the young kids
at the core of the series have been
brutalized by a system that was built to
automatically assume the worst of young
black men like them these characters
have been traumatized and the fact that
they are eventually exonerated does not
erase what has happened to them when
they see us sheds a light on the crime
that was perpetrated against these boys
and what it reveals is devastating they
were totally unable to defend themselves
and so they were swallowed up by a
vicious establishment the fact that
they're spat out again is little comfort
to anyone
a tv show about the aids crisis was
never going to be a great time but it's
a sin is still a particularly horrifying
reminder of what the early days of aids
were truly like in the uk the show
follows a group of young gay londoners
who are thrilled to be able to live
their lives as who they really are
slowly though the unfolding aids crisis
invades and transforms those lives as
well as the world around them by the end
of the show several of the main
characters have died and the show's
final moments are rooted in the show's
protagonist succumbing to the virus he
was once vibrant cocky and full of life
but he dies alone in his childhood
bedroom cut off from his friends by his
panicked homophobic mother it's a sin is
about what it meant to be gay during
this era and how aids redefined an
entire generation of people it's also
about a few particular young men whose
lives are cut tragically short the
finale brings this tragedy into sharp
and unforgettable focus
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]